y miles de desplazados climáticos esa ha
sido una de las consecuencias que
dejaron los huracanes y otra y esta a su
paso por centroamérica y colombia como
muchas regiones siguen incomunicadas
todavía no se sabe a ciencia cierta
cuántas personas tuvieron que abandonar
sus hogares en nicaragua el cálculo es
de 160 mil desplazados sólo por yota
mientras que en el salvador han evacuado
a más de 900 personas
sin hogar es por lo menos 100 de los
casi 6.000 habitantes de providencia en
colombia fueron evacuados a la vecina
isla de san andrés pero sus familiares
los esperaban con abrazos ante la
felicidad de confirmar que habían
sobrevivido al huracán otros siguen a la
espera pues las islas de providencia y
santa catalina permanecen incomunicadas
con el resto del país lo peor la gente
ahora en este momento están en las
calles durmiendo en las calles en
nicaragua el daño fue el doble eta
idiota primero golpearon al país en el
municipio de bilwi y lo poco que uno
dejó en pie lo destruyó el otro huracán
dos semanas después ahora muchos de los
40 mil habitantes no tienen a donde ir
me perdí toda mi casa mira ya no tengo
nada ni el poste no tengo
y ahorita estamos en un abajo de una
casa y tenemos plástico para cobre la
situación se repite a lo largo de
centroamérica en la lima decenas de
hondureños se desplazaron de sus hogares
luego de las inundaciones por el
desborde del río chamelecón y en el
salvador los centenares de evacuados de
zonas de alto riesgo viven temporalmente
en más de 1000 albergues en medio de la
pandemia que no da tregua